her man in there with her child a baby's
arm of a joint dangling out of his mouth
I was like hey Megan um you know I
wanted to talk to you about this moment
and he just went ballistic no just
goes from zero to like awesome like rage
and awesome super angry it kind of went
Maniac mode
who's the maniac apparently Machine Gun
Kelly he's the most talented boy in the
world that's according to girlfriend
Megan Fox's co-star Tyson Ritter he was
fully unhinged and I was just like okay
man I'm just gonna receive you the
All-American Rejects front man who
dabbles in acting speaks out on the tuna
on toast with Striker podcast I don't
expect you to under
recounting MGK's alleged blower in this
in the film there was this uh there's a
scene that I she basically teases me
putting my my fingers in her mouth I'm
like her henchman my team are all over
it
no
we're on set I go over to Megan's
trailer her man in there with her name
this Coulson guy
um who you know was yes as Machine Gun
Kelly yes well it's just hard to be away
from someone that you love I was like
hey Megan um you know I wanted to talk
to you about this moment where you know
when you die because you've been teasing
putting my fingers in your mouth that
when you're dead I put my fingers in you
give it to me and it's like this sort of
resolution to my character like getting
his revenge Coulson like
just
goes from zero to like awesome like rage
and awesome super angry yeah sounds like
Coulson wasn't down for any script
changes
uh he was super bummed about me asking
if I could put my fingers in Megan Fox's
mouth and I knew I knew she was right
there and he just went ballistic no it
kind of went Maniac mode and I was like
it's funny man like I just kind of held
the space for it and he might have been
having a bad day because obviously yeah
it wasn't gonna be anything crazy and
Megan was such a sweetheart to work with
that it was kind of just a really
singular moment uh so yeah that's that
story yeah but what if Megan and MGK's
Love Story That's Crazy Fire the twin
flames romance heated up Sports
illustrated's Red Carpet where an
eyewitness inside told us the two were
laughing and being affectionate
meanwhile a source tells E.T the couple
has been making an effort to work out
their issues and MGK has been going out
of his way to make Megan feel happy
loved and secure they both have so much
fun together and feel comfortable with
one another and that hasn't changed love
is probably the biggest project I've
ever worked on yeah as for that looming
wedding date when it needs to happen
it'll open up the universe will open it
up and we'll do it
[Music]